endlich sie sind da die impfstoffe gegen
korona ich persönlich bin mega happy
aber manche fragen sich jetzt schon
normalerweise dort aus doch um die zehn
jahre bis man einen impfstoff entwickelt
hat manchmal sogar noch viel viel länger
jetzt sind impfstoffe gegen korona nach
nicht mal einem jahr fertig die mit
abstand schnellste impfstoff entwicklung
der menschheitsgeschichte
zum glück muss man eigentlich sagen noch
nie hat die gesamte weltöffentlichkeit
so sehr auf einen impfstoff hingefiebert
wie auf die hingegen saß kauf 2 denn
mittlerweile wurden bereits über 100
millionen menschen weltweit infiziert
zwei millionen davon sind gestorben
wenn wir dieses virus besiegen und
wieder halbwegs zur normalität
zurückkehren wollen
dann gibt es derzeit nur einen weg
mindestens 70 prozent von uns müssen
geimpft werden wahrscheinlich sogar
deutlich mehr
doch bei der geschwindigkeit mit der
dieser impfstoff entwickelt wurde ist es
kein wunder dass manche da erst mal
skeptisch sind
wie war das möglich wie entwickelt man
einen impfstoff in nur einem jahr und
ist ja auch wirklich sicher wir haben
uns das mal genauer angeschaut
die bundesweite impfaktion gegen das
carola virus hat begonnen
wir haben unser projekt
lichtgeschwindigkeit oder live speed
genannt
die absoluten kompetenz
oliver hartwin card je mehr menschen
geimpft werden umso größer wird dann
auch in der bevölkerung das vertrauen
werden bevor wir zu cola kommen erstmal
die frage wie sieht denn so eine normale
impfstoffentwicklung aus also wenn nicht
gerade eine pandemie herrscht und
millionen von menschen infiziert sind
am anfang eines impfstoffes steht immer
die forschung wie reagiert unser
immunsystem überhaupt auf den erreger
wie können wir es dazu bringen
antikörper zu bilden
denn das ist das ziel von impfstoffen
wenn euro bio kenntnisse aus der schule
auch etwas eingerostet sind hier noch
mal ein auf frischer unser immunsystem
ist sozusagen der türsteher unseres
körpers und es braucht teilweise mehrere
tage um antikörper gegen einen
unbekannten erreger zu bilden
diese antikörper attackieren dann den
ungebetenen gast und vernichten ihnen
anschließend merkt sich unser körper in
so genannten t gedächtniszellen wie es
antikörper gegen diesen erreger baut
wenn man sich dann noch mal infiziert
können die antikörper sofort hergestellt
werden und das ist super wichtig denn
diese wenigen tage die es bei der ersten
infektion dauert bis antikörper gebildet
werden sind kritisch in dieser zeit kann
sich der erreger bereits so stark
ausgebreitet haben dass das immunsystem
nicht mehr dagegen ankommt wir werden
krank um den virus hier einen schritt
voraus zu sein gibt es impfstoffe
sie zeigen den immunsystem eine
ungefährliche version des erregers oder
ob sogar nur einen teil von ihm
bevor er zum ersten mal tatsächlich im
körper ist so können schon mal
antikörper entworfen werden wenn die
krankheit dann tatsächlich vor der tür
steht muss unser immunsystem nur noch
den bauplan für die antikörper aus der
schublade ziehen und kann den erreger
direkt ab werk und wir werden nicht
krank ok so weit so gut so eine methode
zu finden also wie man dem körper den
erreger gefahrlos zeigen kann ist aber
gar nicht so einfach
häufig braucht es dafür viele jahre
forschung warum wir diesmal viel
schneller sein konnten dazu kommen wir
gleich schauen uns erst mal noch weiter
die normale entwicklung an
sobald die forschenden einen wirkstoff
gefunden haben kommt als nächstes groß
angelegte wissenschaftliche studien
davon gibt es alleine vier beaufort
überhaupt einen zulassungsantrag
gestellt werden kann
als erstes die präklinischen versuchen
das sind tests im labor
dabei wird zum beispiel geguckt ob der
impfstoff die gewünschte immunantwort
provoziert und ob tiere ihnen generell
vertragen
danach geht es in die
zwischen tests mit drei phasen in der
ersten wird der impfstoff an einer
handvoll menschen getestet um zu sehen
ob menschen ihnen vertragen wenn da
alles gut läuft dann wird einer etwas
größeren gruppe menschen verabreicht und
es wird geschaut ob er auch im menschen
die gewünschte immunantwort erzeugt dass
die zweite phase wie groß die
eigentliche schutzwirkung des
impfstoffes müssen also das was wir
wirklich eigentlich erreichen wollen das
wird in der dritten phase an einer
großen gruppe freiwilliger getestet jede
phase muss dabei erst mal erfolgreich
abgeschlossen werden damit es in die
nächste gehen kann
das alles kann viele jahre dauern wenn
dann alle klinischen studien
abgeschlossen sind und ergeben dass der
impfstoff sicher ist und dass er auch
wirklich wird dann kann man sich zwar
freuen aber dann kommt das was ich
persönlich im alltag absolut tasse
nämlich papierkram
denn der zulassungsprozess kann echt
lange dauern dafür gibt es verschiedene
verfahren
wir schauen uns jetzt mal dass der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur kurz
denn ihr überlief auch das
zulassungsverfahren für den impfstoff
von biontech der hier bei uns zuerst
zugelassen wurde
hinter diesem sperrigen namen
europäische arzneimittelagentur stehen
zahlreiche gremien und forschende die
den impfstoff überprüfen so kann das
mittel zentral für die ganze eu
zugelassen werden anschließend prüft das
paul ehrlich institut die deutsche
impfstoff zulassungsstelle die
impfstoffdosen trotzdem noch einmal
bevor sie dann letztendlich ausgeliefert
werden
für eine zulassung muss ein impfstoff
hohe auflagen erfüllen denn er wird
einem gesunden menschen gegeben das
heißt es wird in einen funktionierenden
körper eingegriffen
damit die europäische
arzneimittelagentur hierfür eine
zulassung empfiehlt muss der impfstoff
also extrem sicher sein denn die ewig
für jede impfung immer kosten und nutzen
gegeneinander ab wie gut schützt das
mittel vor einer krankheit und wie
dringend wird es gebraucht was wir haben
auf der anderen seite potenzielle
negative konsequenzen wenn jemand zum
beispiel eine impfung gegen hiv
entwickeln würde dann würden wir als
nebenwirkung zwei wochen mit übelkeit
und fieber durchaus in kauf nehmen bei
einem mittel gegen erkältungen
wahrscheinlich eher nicht für das ganze
verfahren braucht alleine die
arzneimittelagentur normalerweise 210
tage und so etwa ein dreiviertel jahr
und dann kommen noch die ganzen monate
hinzu die der hersteller für das
erstellen von mehreren tausend seiten
zulassungspapieren braucht es dann heißt
es so der impfstoff ist endlich
zugelassen
hurra aber jetzt bringt ja der
hersteller erst an sich nach
produktionsstätten umzusehen
bis tatsächlich der erste impfstoff
hergestellt ist könnten noch mal viele
monate bis hin zu jahren ins land gehen
so viel zeit hatten wir bei krone hat
natürlich nicht also jetzt die zehn
billionen euro frage wie konnten wir
diesen allen langen prozess von der
forschung bis zur auslieferung
beschleunigen
eine wichtige zutat ist natürlich
personal in den zulassungsbehörden
arbeiten derzeit deutlich mehr menschen
als üblich an der prüfung der impfstoffe
beim hersteller bei und tag haben sie im
frühjahr 2020 sogar rund um die uhr im
drei schicht betrieb gearbeitet
klar dass entwicklung und prüfung so
schnell agieren als wenn alle beamten
auf ihre drei kaffeepausen tag kochen
und normalerweise dauert es mehrere
monate bis über ein jahr bis genug
versuchs teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen
gefunden sind aber für die klinischen
studien mit dem corona im stoff haben
sich im vergangenen jahr innerhalb von
wenigen monaten mehrere zehntausend
menschen gemeldet die ersten menschen
die den impfstoff nach der zulassung
bekommen haben sind also bei weitem
nicht die ersten menschen die den
impfstoff bekommen haben
eine zweite ganz wichtige stellschraube
war der papierkram
normalerweise muss eine forschungsgruppe
alle zulassungsunterlagen fertig
ausfüllen bevor sie sie einreichen kann
irgendwo logisch erst dann wenn alles
vorliegt fangen die prüfstellen an die
unterlagen zu lesen und wahrscheinlich
selbst dann nicht sofort denn man kommt
ja meistens erst mal ganz unten unter
dem stapel bei den corona impfstoffen
durften die impfstoff entwickeln die
papiere nun aber in teilschritten
einreichen
rowling review heißt das und ist in etwa
so als ob ihr bei einer klausur jede
aufgabe die er fertig habt direkt
abgeben könnte damit schon mal
korrigiert werden kann
während ihr die nächste aufgabe
bearbeitet durch das beschleunigte
zulassungsverfahren konnten schon nach
150 tagen und nicht nach dem üblichen
210 tagen entschieden werden ob der
impfstoff zugelassen wird
die sogenannte bedingte zulassung spart
ebenfalls zeit dank ihr können die
hersteller einige weniger wichtige
unterlagen nachreichen während der
impfstoff schon verabreicht werden kann
dieses verfahren ist jedoch keine
notfall zulassung ganz ganz wichtiger
unterschied die notfall zulassung ist
nämlich eigentlich gar keine zulassung
sondern im gegenteil nur die erlaubnis
ein mittel zu verabreichen obwohl noch
gar keine zulassung da ist die bedingte
zulassung hingegen ist eine richtige
zulassung mit ausführlicher prüfung
klaren regeln
und hoher transparenz sieg an den
hersteller im gegensatz zu den nur
zulassungen zu zahlreichen prüfungen und
auflagen verpflichten und genau das war
hierbei corona auch der fall
ein weiterer wichtiger faktor um
innerhalb eines jahres einen impfstoff
zu entwickeln ist überraschung geld
während forscher normalerweise lange
sponsoren für ihre forschung suchen
müssen standen für den crooner impfstoff
direkt mehrere millionen zur verfügung
damit konnten zum beispiel manche
studienphasen parallel statt
nacheinander durchgeführt werden was ein
finanzielles risiko darstellt es gab
sogar so viel geld dass manche
hersteller bereits fabriken für die
impfstoffproduktion bauen konnten obwohl
sie noch gar nicht wussten ob ihr im
stoff wirken würde das alles spart uns
gerade richtig viel zeit
außerdem wir haben mit der forschung
nicht bei null angefangen denn das kauft
zwei hat viele geschwister eines davon
ist zum beispiel das virus mehr als das
bereits vor einigen jahren zum ersten
mal aufgetreten ist hiergegen war der
impfstoff bereits halb fertig als saas
kauf zwei uns getroffen hat hinzu kommen
20 jahre grundlagenforschung zu
generieren und auch die m rna forschung
gab es schon lange
ja die korona impfstoffe sind die
allerersten für den menschen
zugelassenen m rna impfstoffe und das
heißt nicht dass wir nicht schon lange
daran geforscht haben das wissen aus
diesen studien konnten die forschen sind
nun nutzen um sehr schnell einen
impfstoff gegen korona zu entwickeln es
war also einfach auch ein bisschen glück
im riesengroßen unglück also ist bei der
schnellen impfstoff entwicklung hier in
der eu etwas nicht mit rechten dingen
zugegangen
der anreiz als erster den impfstoff
fertig zu haben war ja durchaus sehr
groß aber wenn jemand irgendwo bei der
impfstoffentwicklung gepfuscht haben
sollte dann hätte es entweder der
behördlichen prüfung der laborpraxis den
inspektionen der klinischen tests dem
europaweiten fehlermeldesystem der
europäischen zulassungsbehörde ema deren
prüfenden aus zwei verschiedenen staaten
die ihren gutachter innenfach
ausschüssen und arbeitsgruppen deren
ausschuss für humanarzneimittel mit
mitgliedern aus allen eben
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
ethikkommission der hersteller erlaubnis
und überwachung oder der deutschen
zulassungsbehörde dem
paul-ehrlich-institut auffallen müssen
damit ein fehlerhafter impfstoff trotz
all dieser sicherheitsmechanismen auf
den markt kommt hätten die alle kennen
müssen und um das ernsthaft zu glauben
müsste man wahrscheinlich auch glauben
dass wir in wahrheit alle
von axon menschen kontrolliert werden
also wir haben hier wirklich gründlich
recherchiert und alle quellen haben wir
euch ganz transparent unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und immer wenn ich
hier so eine blaue zahl seht dann findet
ihr darunter den beleg für die
entsprechende aussage mir wurde gerade
gesagt dass die ba zahle immer da
auftauchen wir haben auch mit vielen
expertinnen und experten für dieses
video gesprochen sogar aus dem
prüfinstituten selber und es deutet
nichts darauf hin dass irgendjemand
unsauber gearbeitet hätte nichts ist
weggelassen worden stattdessen es
einfach viel gleichzeitig passiert und
ein bisschen glück hatten wir auch
dadurch und durch die großen mengen an
personal geld und kooperation war es
möglich dass die wissenschaft diese
meisterleistung geschafft hat einen
impfstoff in nicht einmal einem jahr zu
entwickeln
und ich kann es kaum erwarten dass ich
an der reihe bin mit impfen wenn ihr
jetzt genau wissen wollte wie der korona
impfstoff eigentlich funktioniert dann
kann ich euch die debatte empfehlen die
debatte wird von der gemeinnützigen
organisation wissenschaft im dialog
gemeinsam mit der technischen
universität braunschweig betrieben und
stellt für euch wissenschaftliche fakten
und interviews zu großen
gesellschaftlichen themen zusammen
gerade jetzt zum beispiel impfstoff
dort findet ihr zum beispiel auch
artikel darüber wie wir den impfstoff
weltweit gerecht verteilen können was
impfen mit vertrauen zu tun hat und was
den vorsitzenden der deutschen impfstoff
kommission am corona impfstoff
überrascht hat spannendes interview
das und noch viele weitere themen findet
ihr auf der website von die debatte das
verlange ich euch gerne alles unten in
der video beschreibung noch alle artikel
die ich gerade genannt hat das sind da
unten verlinkt wenn er jetzt noch
weitere fragen zum impfstoff haben dann
schreibt uns die gerne unten in die
kommentare
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt neugierig
bleibt gesund wie gut schützt das mittel
vor einer krankheit und wie dringend
wird diese krankheit gerade vernichtet
gebraucht